mathematicians have come up with a  Rapunzel number that can predict the  shape of any ponytail solving a problem  that has perplexed hairdressers since  Leonardo da Vinci post it 500 years ago  the ponytail equation balances gravity  versus the springiness of hair to  predict whether ponytails will be  fan-like  or flow downwards the ponytail equation  is r is the radius of the ponytail the  first term is elasticity or the  resistance to bend the second term is  tension third is weight and then  pressure of the individual hairs pushing  against each other  involved in this is the Rapunzel number  which tells us of our ponytail will  droop down or not it is mathematics that  could be helpful to shampoo brands or  animators trying to model more realistic  hair